[Music]
[Applause]
hello and the styles are critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well us
a lot of you know last week I did a top
eleven list of the worst avatar pisode
with the understanding there's really no
such thing as a bad Abbot our episode
just Sunday aren't as good as others
well this week I'm going from the worst
are the best to the best of the best
avatar is one of the most amazing shows
ever put on the air its stories
intriguing its characters lovable his
messages thought-provoking
its philosophy and lightning and its
animation incredible so as you'd imagine
finding the absolute best of this series
is no easy task
there are so many great episodes with so
many great moments but we're here to
discriminate for the best and that's
exactly what we're gonna do so let's not
waste any time and take a look at the
top 11 best episodes why top 11 because
I like to go one step beyond so sit back
and enjoy the top 11
Dante Bosco you and miss on the
franchises so have dishonored me the
time has come to reclaim my honor you
dishonorably discharged with my
honorably honoring my honorable honor
okay I have no idea what you just said
right now don't worry you'll feel it
what is it
it's nothing fucking Bosco I think you'd
like the cactus juice or something
he thinks he's one of the characters
from Avatar don't dress in the
appropriate attire maybe who can
distract him right look it's okay I'm
doing a top 11 best avatar episodes you
don't deserve the chance okay look maybe
we come to a compromise I can give you a
really glowing review and take the lead
it's time to fight fire with fire and
soak them knows how to do it and us lost
boys to stick together Tamra that's not
avatar
that's hook what are you talking like a
pirate why the Pirates talk about
pirates oh now you need to try harder I
want you to go home do some research
keep me updated on your progress okay
okay all right buddy it's time to show
you who's boss
well we'll show you who's boss right
crack credit sorry Malcolm heaven needs
of me outweigh the needs of you that's
show business for you just try to keep
him entertained while I start the
countdown why don't we go ahead
[Music]
the ember island players the irony is I
was almost one step away from putting
this on the worst episodes list because
in many respects it is little to do with
anything
team avatar sees the Fire Nation is
putting on a play of their travels and
even though it's phenomenally dangerous
they decided to check it out what
follows is a theatrical interpretation
of their adventures only it's done from
an incredibly biased and exaggerated
angle pissing all of them off there are
one or two moments of emotional
exposition but for the most part it's
just watching the play as an episode
little happens but as a series recap
that actually works its way into the
show itself it's actually friggin
brilliant it's explaining everything
that's happened on the show except with
a comedic edge making fun of theatrical
tropes story tropes and even their own
character tropes Katara for example is
too inspiring ly emotional we cannot
give up hope well that's just silly I
like that Toph is a giant male
Neanderthal I released a sonic wave from
my mouth and Zuko is always too much of
an angsty sourpuss let's forget about
the avatar and get massages how could
you say that I think of all the other
shows that do series recaps and they're
usually just clipped shows or something
separate that just has a narrator
telling you what happened but they
decide to take it in a different
direction actually incorporating it into
the story truth be told I can't think of
any other show that has ever done that
at least in this clever away it
incorporates the characters reaction to
the whole thing not just their own
adventures but to the villains
interpretation of their adventures and
their satire both Broadway and movie
styles in fact could this be interpreted
as the character's reaction to the last
airbender movie that wasn't a good play
no kidding horrible you said it but the
effects were decent this may not be the
most important or dramatic of the
episodes but it is one of the most
clever and funny and on that level it
definitely deserves
number eleven spot so far this
intermission is the best part of the
play the chase this one is very similar
to the drill where most of the episode
is just one big action sequence but the
reason I put this one over the drill is
not only is the action sequence really
intense and brilliantly planned out but
it also allows for character
interactions you wouldn't normally see
top an iro for example share a touching
talk throughout all the chaos mostly
because they have no idea who they are
or that they're on opposite sides so
where is your nephew is he lost yes a
little bit I know he doesn't wanna be
around right now but if he needs me I'll
be there it's a really unique relaxing
moment among super extreme intense
panicking
Zuko fights a gang fights Azula Azula
fight Zuko it's a Mexican standoff of
all the coolest combinations you can
think of it just feels so sorry for our
heroes in this one all we want to do is
get a good night's rest but as ULA's
posse is constantly on their back never
letting up this not only adds to the
suspense but also just what an
all-around kick-ass villain Azula really
is she's a fucking machine of evil and
she makes sure everybody knows it
nothing seems to slow her down the
intensity just keeps going and going and
going and getting more and more insane
and crazy it's just a huge rush by the
time it's over you feel like you need a
nap which is exactly how the episode
ends well certainly not devoid of story
or character sometimes the best way to
sympathize with your hero is just to put
them in the middle of what they're going
through
to feel that racing heartbeat to feel
that running out of breath and in this
one you feel every second of that panic
the Fighting's great the layouts great
the characters are great it'll make sure
you sleep damn well after watching it so
what's our plan don't know T ty
the firebending masters after Zuko joins
the team he agrees to finish Aang's
firebending training the problem is
Zuko's bending has gone downhill because
he doesn't have the rage he used to so
they have to travel to the original
source the closest thing they have is a
civilization thousands of years old
known as the Sun warriors the ancient
ruins however have a lot of tricky booby
traps that indicates something is still
kicking sure enough not only are there
still people living out there but holy
shit
mother fucking dragons fuck Game of
Thrones this is the first one that
dropped the dragon bomb these are the
Masters I never said that however just
like in Game of Thrones the reaction is
exactly the same
you simply can't believe they exist in
this world you think you have a grasp of
how it works because you identify with
the character so much and how they have
a grasp on the world so when they're
surprised to see these things are still
alive
you're just as shocked on top of that
the episode does great at not only
explaining how bending is an extension
of oneself but showing it when inside
the dragon's fire they see various
colors they didn't even know fire could
make it's the equivalent of going
through the Stargate in 2001 it's
beautiful and otherworldly they judged
you and gave you visions of the meaning
of firebending these shows especially
family shows can give that experience
this large without having to explain it
but this one did it just let the moments
beat for itself it was pretty damn
memorable it was a great episode for
Zuko and Aang to work off each other it
was great for their explanation of what
one skills are capable of and it was
great for giving us one fiery hell of an
incredible experience
the day of the Black Sun this two-parter
is probably the biggest battle the show
has had yeah at least in the size of
people and characters practically
everybody you've seen in the show comes
together to try and take down the
Firelord
it's the day of the Eclipse where all
the firebenders lose their power and
this day has been built up for several
episodes at least half the season so you
can imagine what a hard crippling stab
in the balls it is to see every
conceivable thing that can go wrong go
wrong the fire Lord knows about the
attack and is taken away a Zulu is there
to distract them and God damage he's
pretty damn good at even without her
bending and just when you think they're
going to leave her and find the Fire
Lord my favorite prisoner used to
mention you all the time oh no Sokka
don't worry she was convinced you were
going to come rescue her don't listen
Sokka no you got Nations to say why
can't you I hate you I hate you the
episode ends with everyone getting
captured except for our few young heroes
we can't leave you behind the youngest
of our groups to go with you the adults
will stay behind and surrender and just
when you think all hope is lost it's
just been one terrible moment after
goddamn terrible moment a huge twist
happens Zuko leaves his father to join
the avatar leaving a glimpse of hope for
their future I'm going to join the
avatar
and I'm going to help him defeat you
goodbye
good god men talk about an epic middle
of the season you end up hating the bad
guys even more but you get so invested
in how the good guys are going to win
the day
it's the perfect halfway point the
Empire Strikes Back of the final season
so much greatness destroy but so much
potential to be born
that's one eclipse to remember critic
it's okay I took care of Bosco oh great
I knew you could take him yourself
but wait where's Malcolm damn it Malcolm
I definitely broke under pressure sorry
I was wait you just can't get good help
that's how I could bag nice more ladies
in my cab
something connected to firebending
around here here we go alright Dante I
think you've met your match no no no
Tamara it's wrong costume again no I'm a
ninja
no no it doesn't matter we have a theme
going and we need to stick to the theme
understand I kind of like it
hey this doesn't concern you now look I
want you to go home do some research and
call me when you finally wiki something
okay fine it's a good try thank you hey
don't encourage him
- man you stupid stupid man guests
so that's why I have no Imam all right
we get the multitask here a little bit
and get to learn how to firebend while
also continuing the countdown so with
that said listen one Zucco alone leaving
his uncle Iroh Zuko travels to the
middle of nowhere on his own to discover
his true path isolated from everyone who
knows him he befriends a small family
who he constantly saves from a group of
psychotic bullies while doing this we
get flashbacks to a time when Zuko
actually had a family a happy one even
he tries to remember what it's like to
belong with someone who loves you these
are dual swords don't think of them as
separate because they're not I think
you'd really like my brother Sen su he
has to show me stuff like this all the
time only to find the past will never
fully let him go especially when people
discover who you are not a step closer
it's yours you should have it no I hate
you look at that he saves this kid's ass
trying to start over and be good again
but as soon as it's revealed he's the
fire Prince he's an outcast once more
fuckin a man this whole episode is like
a movie Clint Eastwood would direct you
know the ones where you see someone gets
shit on and in the end you just say life
sucks but I mean that a good way the
classic sort of Greek tragedy way it's
soaked in the poignancy in the sadness
of the character it's like something out
of Frankenstein or a gothic novel the
journey of one who's truly lost in
society may deem should never be found
showing once again how the redeemable
are not so easily redeemed if even at
all
you just feel so sorry for this kid you
know he's the villain but you just want
life to cut him a break for once well a
break that doesn't emotionally kick his
ass and yet of course we know things
would eventually come full circle for
him but in this episode only the lost
walk alone
[Music]
number six the puppet master I'm sure
for years fans have asked the question
why waterbenders can't bend the human
body seeing how it's mostly made out of
water well the writers decided to give
an episode right out of a Halloween
story our gang comes across an old lady
in the woods she seems friendly in kind
and even seems to help Katara learn
elements of waterbending she never
thought possible it then turns out they
were elements she wish he never knew
were possible for when the moon is full
she possesses the art of blood bending
Oh doesn't that term sound so creepy the
art of bending a person to your every
whim she uses it to torture civilians
and force them to rot away in a cave and
it's up to Katara to decide whether or
not she should use this unnatural power
to save her friends or to deny something
so evil and its design once you perfect
this technique you can control anything
or anyone that's tress MacNeille the
voice of dodd giving one hell of a
creepy performance understanding clearly
why she's become this way but also
realizing she's transforming to
something truly disturbed the idea of
controlling another's body doesn't seem
that scary compared to other things in
life but the way they animate and
describe it it's almost like being
possessed by a demon hell you can almost
argue that's what it is it's just so
unsettling I've never felt more
the shadows are heavy the angles twisted
and the atmosphere dark it's a perfect
episode to watch when you want to get
your blood tingling a guru this is the
episode just before the season finale of
season 2 and it does a great job
balancing out calm and meditative
spirituality with brooding trouble
floating on the horizon Aang's team
appears to be safe in Ba Sing se
hell even Zuko seems happy having opened
a tea shop with his uncle so he travels
to a wise guru to open up his chakras to
better understand and control the Avatar
state the only problem is as Ulla and
her gang are posing as Kyoshi warriors
and are taking the palace over from the
inside out on top of that Toph has been
captured to bring her back home this
episode is intriguing in how one minute
you can be in such wisdom Lee bliss and
then the next you can be in such an
uncomfortable place everything builds on
top of one another as one group is
getting closer to peace another is
getting closer to tragedy again the
episode has a strong resemblance to the
Empire Strikes Back
in fact the similarities are almost
downright eerie right down to the main
hero leaving his training from his wise
master to go save his friends Katara's
in danger I have to go if you leave now
you won't be able to go into the Avatar
state at all doing most great stories it
doesn't feel like a ripoff or like an
understanding of when and where to put
the most perilous moments and the best
thing is the person who achieves victory
at the end of this isn't one of the
people we focused on throughout most of
the story
it's not a Azula or even Iroh and Zuko
it's Toph who has spent all her time
locked in a metal box learning how to
friggin metalbend something that's never
been done before
the greatest earthbender in the world
don't you two dunderheads
so even though the whole episode is just
building to the next one it still has an
amazing resolution for one of our
characters still giving us a
self-contained uplifting ending while
also delivering a creepy cliffhanger
again keeping in the bizarre mix of the
episodes tone whether mindful
enlightenment or dreaded anticipation
this episode knew how to get us excited
for what was coming next this can't be
good news
haha I think I got it what an engaging
read all right you Filipino Benjamin
Button space the power my firebending
you know I loved you in Slumdog
Millionaire wait no that wasn't you I'm
sorry I always confuse you with your
fourth-wall jokes won't save you
I'll put these comments is a good use
[Music]
I'm out of ammo
just wieners overrated
[Music]
wait don't do it you're going to hit the
commercial
[Music]
[Applause]
number fucking the southern Raiders
after joining the Avatar Zuko has get
the fine comfortable ground with Katara
who still feels betrayed by his actions
in the previous episode so he gives her
the one thing she's been seeking most
revenge for mother's death he mages to
Loki where the soldier who murdered her
mother most likely would be and they set
out to find him and deliver that just as
he deserves upon locating him she finds
he's nothing more than a sad pathetic
waste who is willing to throw his own
mother under the tracks to save his own
life I did a bad thing
I know I did and you deserve revenge so
why don't you take my mother
that would be fair there's just nothing
inside you nothing at all you're
pathetic and sad and empty in the end
she finds killing him would solve
nothing but in an interesting twist
especially for a family show she doesn't
forgive him forgiveness is the first
step you have to take to begin healing
but I didn't forgive him I'll never
forgive him usually this would be a big
no-no for arguably the most ethical
person on the show not to forgive
someone but in this case they make it
very relatable it doesn't say whether or
not this is a good thing or a bad thing
it's just how she feels and feeling that
way is totally understandable it's a
quarter as well as powerful compromise
Mae Whitman the voice of Katara
gives a great chilling performance in
this and the animation and visual
support her struggle beautifully you
understand everything she's going
through yet are still surprised at some
of her actions especially ones oh my god
she's bluffing she's fucking blood this
is also a great moment in seeing Katara
and Zuko finally come together
and not in that way what's wrong with
you people
he's got the emo goth chick he'll be
happily miserable together
I'm never happy it's powerful it's
emotional it's the perfect way to follow
through on years of the crossroads of
destiny this is what the Guru was
building up to and it didn't disappoint
well the first season finale was
open-ended it did still seem to wrap up
a lot of things for the most part the
season 2 finale however leaves
everything in shambles with big
surprises popping up hardcore action
scenes and pretty much the destruction
of everything our heroes were supposed
to protect
Azula puts her plan into motion to seize
the city of Ba Sing se by manipulating
the leader of the guards leading to
possibly my favorite Azula line of all
time you've beaten me at my own game
don't flatter yourself you were never
even a player oh god what a bitch she's
so fucking awesome
she also captured Aang's friends as well
as Zuko and Iroh giving Zuko the option
to come back home if he agrees to
destroy the avatar with her well Zuko
seems so happy with his tea shop and his
uncle surely he was
it's not even that Zuko made the switch
it's that he betrayed his uncle his damn
uncle who was with him through thick and
thin the guy who never gave up on him
even though he took him for granted so
many times what the backstabbing hell
and just when you think things couldn't
possibly get any worse
Aang is told that if he's killed in the
Avatar State the avatars will never be
reborn again and what ends up happening
if I could borrow from my Chris Tucker
folder here no of course Katara
saves them by bringing him back to life
but dude for a second we thought the
Avatar cycle was dead that was a pretty
damn scary moment there so we leave on
the note where not only are the heroes
beaten and torn but the villains have
taken over even more land the possible
ally has turned back into a villain and
they are hunted more now than they have
ever been throughout the entire series
damn that is harsh this show knows how
to do a good cliffhanger you had to wait
a whole year until you figured out where
this was going next it was cruel it was
sick it was freaking awesome
yeah it had us by the balls but we were
just too damn curious to see where the
hell they were gonna take the earth
Kingdom
number two the store while the first
season up to this point was mostly
action and fun this was the episode that
made fans realized there was something
more to it something ridged something
deep something that took a lot of
thought and could be executed
brilliantly the storm dives into the
back stories of both our hero and our
villain both are told around the
fireplace during a thunderous rampage
outside the perfect setting for talk of
epic tragedies egg reveals how he was
told he was going to be the avatar and
how he ran away knowing he would have
the weight of the world on his shoulders
most likely during a time of war and
death pyro tells us Zuko's backstory
about how he was a well-meaning young
man who called out the motives of a
general which resulted in a duel a duel
he didn't know at the time that was
against his father ashamed and afraid he
refused to fight resulting in the Fire
Lord burning his face and banished him
within one Episode everything falls into
place with these two characters
everything that could practically be
understood about them is suddenly
understood they may be enemies but
they're very similar they're ruled by
the bad choices they made in the past
and their guild decides their actions
while one hides behind fun and games the
other hides behind ruthlessness and
discipline two different but similar
outcomes from two different but similar
starting points the episode ends with
them exchanging a look it's only for a
second but the connection is definitely
there whether they realize it or not
confuse naive innocent staring down
confused emotional anger it's a chilling
moment and one of the show's best this
was the point for many when they
realized this wasn't just a smart
cartoon show this was something that
could leave an impact something that had
a plan something we were feeling more
and more was in outstanding downright
genius hands we became confident and
where it was going and we
wait to see where it was going it was
exciting it was new it was a totally
different term that the show hadn't
taken before and it only got us more
excited to see what was coming next
[Music]
joy and the number one greatest avatar
episode it prepare to meet the great
melon Lord in the sky oh he'll get my
body takes so much abuse
wait a minute aunty I only have one
episode left the greatest avatar episode
of all time would it be more honourable
if both you and I talked about lights Oh
wonderful
but then you wouldn't be punished the
only one you're punishing is yourself
man I mean look at you you look like the
karate kid with pinkeye you're trying so
hard to show off the best of Zuko for
the fans when really we should be
thankful there either was of Zuko to
begin with
you don't need to do that the only
fucking beautiful dive a Bosco you're
awesome
you don't need to put on this show for
us so what do you say Dante stop with
the Zuko and get with the yoyo you had
me into that last line yeah that really
fucking killed it the rest is pretty
good though thank you so what do you say
man
can we do this why the hell not
[Music]
the number-one avatar episode is sozin's
comet not just one but the final four
parts of season 3 that clearly flow as
one perfectly told episode the turmoil
of all the main characters are addressed
no one is overlooked and everybody is
given a strong and satisfactory
conclusion from Zuko reuniting with his
uncle to toss Sokka and Sookie
performing their biggest mission to
Azula slowly descending into madness and
of course egg dilemma and whether or not
he should kill the Fire Lord
so much is built up and all of it is
relatable and suspenseful we don't know
what's going to happen or how it's going
to happen so we're right there with the
main characters fearing what could be
lost
it's everything an epic conclusion could
ask for it's exciting romantic bunny
suspenseful and showcasing the best
animation the series has ever offered it
pulled no punches with that said there
were some people that had some issues
with the climax for example some people
didn't like how it was Katara and Azul o
who finished the final battle as opposed
to Zuko and Azula
remember that Azula cheated in trying to
haunt Katara which is very fitting of
her character and her deteriorating
mental state Zuko still fought honorably
making a sacrifice allow guitar to give
Azula what she deserved
some also take issue that Aang's defeat
of the Fire Lord is a bit of a deus ex
machina and didn't teach any technical
lessons but the show is not just about
teaching walls it's about spiritual
understanding reinforcing a philosophy
that as bad as things get even over a
long period of time balance will
eventually take shape again and choice
does almost consume him and in the end
he had to find another route that nobody
thought possible he crossed over and
created an alternative that wasn't even
on the table as if the world was so out
of balance that this was inevitable
yet it was still Aang's and risking of
his life that made the transition
possible only one question was on it
where
now available whatever good books are
sold it's an engagement but aside from
then everybody gets the ending most
warrants to see for their favorite
characters nobody's left out everyone is
given the most fitting ending the show
could give you felt like you watched
something not only massive but important
and in a medium where TV shows so often
either go too long or end on a bad note
avatar state just as long as it needed
and ended on the absolute perfect note
possible the size weight and passion are
all there everything the show is
building up to felt perfectly delivered
this episode more than any other made us
realize this wasn't just a show it was
an experience and experience none of
those who watched and loved it will ever
there now wasn't that fun to do Dante
Dante yeah I admit I was spending too
much time focusing on being Zuko if
they're focusing on what's really
important there now you see isn't that
so much better just to be yourself yes
or ha the american dragon jake long what
up what's the dealio don't be all mean
beans boy I've got it I finally got the
right cost
oh fuck you Dante Bosco
[Music]
[Applause]
you
do man you stupid stupid man